I just want to say on behalf of myself  and all of us we couldn't be prouder of  you Michael Strahan and Kelly Ripa made  peace in the week before stray hands  final episode of live with Kelly and  Michael they seem like they're so family  a source tells ET the make up between  the co-host quote wasn't a big  conversation they had or a kumbaya  moment we're told Kelly realized her  issue wasn't really with Michael but  with the network which was a bit evident  on her first day back after the  announcement of Michaels departure  apologies have been made and the best  thing to come out of all of this you  guys is that our parent company has  assured me that live is a priority our  source says Ripa is quote still angry  over being disrespected by her  higher-ups  but another source tells ET she is being  a solid leader for her staff giving them  assurances as a new co-host is chosen  ABC will test options this summer and we  hear Kelly is still pushing hard for her  pal Anderson Cooper